I went on a plant-based diet for 30 days
so is it really the best diet
what is a plant-based diet is it
vegetarian vegan can you eat meat well
the truth is that at the definition of a
plant-based diet differs depending on
who you ask
so generally it is a lifestyle choice
that emphasizes on eating more real
Whole Foods that comes from plants to me
plant-based does not mean completely
eliminating lean sources of protein so
when I started this year I knew that I
needed a cleanse from all the holiday
foods and decided to go on a 30-day
plant-based diet honestly I was a little
bit worried as I know that my body does
not do well consuming lots of beans and
lentils on a daily basis I have a very
sensitive stomach and often feel bloated
because of my IDs so beans and lentils
can cause bloating because of the excess
fiber that I'm taking in plus I'm
intolerant to temper so that's
completely out of the question
knowing my body I decided not to stress
myself out and take a more relaxed
approach at the end of the day you need
to eat according to what works for your
body and not just follow a certain diet
or restrict food or even force yourself
to eat too much of a certain type of
food just because they are healthy so it
really is a process of understanding
your body and how your body reacts to
different foods I didn't completely
eliminate meat as some of you might know
I'm pescetarian so I do consume fish and
seafood because I know that my body
needs high amounts of omega-3s and
vitamin b12 during the entire 30 days I
made sure to add a lot more plant-based
foods especially fresh vegetables into
all my meals so for the first two weeks
I consumed fish for one meal daily and
on the third and fourth week I slowly
reduce it to every alternate days so it
wasn't a drastic change but a gradual
one
now when it comes to consuming beans and
lentils out go for canned beans the
canning process actually helps to break
down some of the cups in the beans
making them a lot easier to digest and
less likely to cause gas if possible
choose the low-sodium option and also be
sure to rinse the beans to reduce the
sodium content another really simple
trick is to soak the beans in water
before you cook them for three to four
hours and this will help it get rid of
some of the gas producing cups so some
of the beans that work well for my body
are black beans and also chickpeas and
that also the reason why you see them
being repeated a lot in my recipes so it
was through a lot of trial throughout
the years I don't consume any dairy as
I'm lactose intolerant
so I've swapped with non-dairy milk such
as unsweetened soy or almond milk what
I've learned about the plant-based diets
is that they promote inclusivity over
exclusivity so it's not asking you to
completely eliminate a food group or
restricting what you can eat such as no
cups or low-fat which you know that I'm
against but rather it's about consuming
a well-balanced diet the emphasizes on
the consumption of healthy real plant
foods such as whole grains fruits
vegetables nuts beans legumes healthy
fats while reducing the intake of
unhealthy plant foods as well as animal
products did I feel hungry when I was
eating more plant fruits not really
because having huge amounts of veggies
really filled me up plus they are low in
calories which can help with weight loss
another common question is did I have a
sense of not feeling satisfied no
because I could still enjoy lots of
healthy complex cups and also healthy
fats such as nuts and avocado which
really helped with my hunger did it
affect my workout honestly no as I was
consuming enough protein from
beans tofu nuts and seeds as well as
fish to be honest it wasn't that
difficult because it didn't differ much
from my previous eating habits and also
my values I didn't feel as bloated
compared to when I tried a vegan
lifestyle because I felt that my food
choices were very limited and those food
didn't do well with my tummy I want to
emphasize that this is a whole food
plant-based diet because you can eat
plant foods but be super unhealthy for
instance eating french fries and cookies
every day it's do a plant-based diet but
it's going to cause more damage to your
body it goes back to the simple
principle of eating real whole food and
avoid fast food desserts sweetened
drinks refined grains packaged foods and
processed meats so how can you make this
transition in seven simple steps if
you've been struggling to make the
transition to eat better or you have
filled in all sorts of different diets
out there then the plant-based approach
may suit you here are seven really
simple steps for you to make that
transition eat more veggies more often
whenever you can emphasize real Whole
Foods versus processed ones fill up on a
salad of veggie heavy soup before your
main meal I have lots of recipes on my
channel switch your typical portion
sizes meant for meat with vegetables so
your plate should be filled up with
vegetables first snack on nuts and seeds
for more fiber and protein drink
unsweetened coffee and tea or cut down
the amount of added sugar enjoy sweets
and treats in small amounts and avoid
stocking them at home what you decide to
avoid is completely up to you so some of
you might consume 100% plant fruits
whereas others such as me might include
some meat even if you do a 70 30 %
plant-based diet trust me your body will
feel a difference and that is kind of
where I am right now
I feel less bloated I have more energy
better focus and honors
I don't crave as much compared to when I
used to restrict my food and beat myself
up over eating a piece of cookie the
bottom line is to not sweat the small
stuff and look at the bigger picture
instead so focus on the big changes such
as consuming less processed food and
more whole fruits and vegetables I would
like to think that the plant-based
eating is a holistic approach to better
health but in a simple and actionable
way that won't overwhelm you
Plus this is long term so on my next
video I will be sharing a 30 day
plant-based
meal plan to help you get started be
sure to stay tuned next week check out
my youtube channel for a lot more
plant-based recipes and give this video
a thumbs up hit the subscribe button and
also turn on your notification button
and be sure to tune in next week for my
plant-based meal plan all the best